hi my name is kim jade it's my absolute
honor to congratulate you mokuru machaba
for being one of the top finalists for
the global teacher prize 2020.
you have been chosen out of over 12 000
nominations across the globe
that's major you overcame every obstacle
you had to walk over eight kilometers
just to get to school
you crossed a river with no school shoes
and you used a rice sack as a bag
you have overcome all of these obstacles
and through it all you've still
succeeded and have been determined to
give your students the best education
possible you've won prizes for
integrating ict into the classroom
introduced your students to coding week
using minecraft and your students have
started learning with other young people
throughout the world
using the microsoft educator platform
that's brilliant
the global teacher prize partners with
unesco and shines a light on inspiring
teachers
just like you across the planet the
world is facing some of its greatest
challenges but backing teachers like you
will light the way
for a brighter future thank you